j'en suis là
[Musique]
il vit dans la musique et le sport
encore debout plein d'abnégation fit
voter adolphe par athlète non voyant
beaucoup de titres et deux records des
blessures et des désillusions aussi mais
rien n'arrête le guépard blanc retour
imminent sur la piste internationale
pour les championnats du monde
le foot ce que tu fais des gammes liasse
de distance de guide le défi se relève
en équipe ce sera bruno sur le 100 m moi
j'ai toujours en phase d'apprentissage
c'est vrai que entre lui et moi par
exemple quand on court c'est moi qui ai
dicté où on s'arrête où on démarre la
position et d'un autre côté c'est lui
qui m'a appris à modifier mes habitudes
que j'avais en tant qu'athlète entre
guillemets individuel je dirais une
grotte là aujourd'hui ce qu'on cherche
noces et les sensations du binôme ces
panneaux sensation à soi et qu'on
additionne c'est vraiment les sensations
du billet non qu'on doit avoir en santé
quitte à ce que tu colles puces mais
n'anticipe pas la sortie pas trop de
décaler tueur c'est un sport individuel
qui devient collectif là l'objectif pour
nous c'est que quand vous voyez de
profil vous voyez qu'un athlète
c'est ce qu'on appelle et courir en
miroir avec geffray sur les 400 en somme
ils ont été champions d'europe en 2018
le lien va bien au delà du sport c'est
beaucoup plus humain et c'est ce qui
fait qu'on arrive à avancer et à s'y
retrouver
dedans plus on est on est content on
n'est jamais de se retrouver on passe de
bons moments ensemble et plus on
apprécie le projet les jeux
paralympiques de taux que 2020 un projet
commun l'olympe de timothée adolphe
[Musique]
une chanson un clip un message on a tous
un peu notre notre moulin pour un
objectif à atteindre et se dire c'est un
morceau dans lequel je dis très
clairement que peu importe les obstacles
les échecs et des illusions parce que
j'en ai eu aussi malheureusement et ben
faut forer un lâcher faut se donner les
moyens de ses de ses ambitions et pour
aller jusqu'au bout le sport la musique
les amis et la famille timothée adolphe
a trouvé son équilibre à l'olympe par
exemple les gp en berceuses adverse des
fouilles s'endort